okay here with chef bruce soul belly uh
boy and you've done a lot uh james beard
you've been on chopped you've been on um
bobby flay's show and also
top chef top chef right okay so you know
what you're doing you gotta check out
this barbecue joint here in the arts
district but today we are making what so
today one of the things that we sell
here that people love is our pimento
cheesecake okay um you know it's
traditional cheese dip from the south
and it's super simple to make
you have cream cheese some shredded
cheddar cheese
camp mentos oh and a little bit of the
juice because we like the flavor and
then just some garlic powder onion
powder smoked paprika and salt and
pepper all things that you can find at
the supermarket yeah exactly okay super
easy to make so
you can i'm going to have you start
mixing that together okay just start
smashing up the cream cheese
fun yeah yeah this is fun with the kids
right this is their my son loves cooking
doing things like this so this is
something that's going to be really easy
to make on the big game super bowl
sunday you don't have to spend too much
time in the kitchen right and so when
you're done mixing it it's going to look
like this oh so these are actually some
glazed pecans that we make they're a
little sweet and i like how it
counteracts with the pimento cheese dip
which is really savory great
so just roll those in nuts and you know
what if you have a nut allergy
just skip the nuts skip the nuts okay
right so that's to find the final
product yeah now are you do you bake
that no no
that's it mix it roll it and serve it
chef this took uh like 30 seconds this
is a great dish cool okay and you serve
it here of course at soul belly we do
yeah not again not the nut balls but we
uh we serve this it's a quick
grab-and-go item for us and it's a big
popular one too i love it all right good
stuff so pimento cheese ball dish number
one you're doing great right there
i have cheese squishing skills did you
know
[Laughter]
of course you don't want to cook at home
no big deal soul belly offering a
tailgate package you can buy it all
complete with everything that you need
and we'll put up a link online so you
can find that at 8newsnow.com